hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's ein kochrezept und zwar
lebt kartoffelbrei mit hähnchen und
tomatensoße das klingt sehr
außergewöhnlich und irgendwie könnte man
meinen es passt nicht zusammen aber
morath
ich habe das heute geträumt dass ich das
feld koch und dann habe ich gedacht
kommt jetzt kocht schluss einfach mal
fraglich ob dabei genau also was
natürlich auch ganz gut dazu passen
würde zudem hähnchen und der
tomatensauce wäre natürlich auch reis
natur heißt zum beispiel das mögen wir
zwar auch ganz gerne aber irgendwie
hatte ich lust wirklich auf
kartoffelpüree und deswegen gibt es eben
auch jetzt zeige ich euch mal kurz da
vorne die zutaten ich werde nämlich
jetzt zuerst die kartoffeln ansetzen und
dann in der zwischenzeit das hähnchen
und die tomatensoße ansetzen und später
wird dann das kartoffelpüree fertig
gestellt also im prinzip fang dir einmal
an und seid dann so in etwa 40 minuten
mit dem kompletten gericht fertig das
ist doch mal was oder
ja also für dieses kartoffelpüree
brauchen wir 750 gramm mehlig kochende
kartoffeln und die restlichen zutaten
seit ich euch dann später die kartoffel
mehlige kartoffeln dann habe ich mein
problem nächsten kartoffeln und bissfest
kochen im medica mit der starken brille
eignet sich besser für das kann doch gar
nicht sein vorwiegend mehlig kochende
kartoffeln die kartoffel zentrum wäre ja
und dann brauchen wir für die
tomatensoße 2 zwiebeln und eine
knoblauchzehe etwa drei esslöffel
tomatenmark zwei dosen gestückelte
tomaten etwas salz und olivenöl
ja du lachst du na ja dann brauche ich
etwas basilikum und thymian und oregano
habe ich hier getrocknet und ich brauch
sechs hähnchenbrustfilets denn wir sind
heute sechs personen als ich brauch
jetzt echt eine große menge eigentlich
schon riechen und ist das keine putin
was ist der unterschied ist ein hähnchen
pute zwei verschiedene tiere
okay die antwort diese wahrscheinlich
erwartet hast ja also ich finde ich als
auch hinten schmecken mir etwas besser
und pute finde ich ja schon phase ringe
und wird auch schneller trocken
natürlich nicht bei uns aber das sind so
deswegen nämlich hinziehen
jetzt mache ich aber zuerst mal das
kartoffelpüree und schneit dafür die
kartoffeln jetzt grad group in große
stücke durch die tatsächlich gefragt was
der unterschied zwischen hinter jörg
butt ist preislich unterschied
das ist ja toll hier ist eure genommen
gut einstecken
ja stimmt ich mag ihn auch mehr
die kartoffeln kommen jetzt direkt in
einen topf da habe ich bereits einen
liter wasser drin und dann denke ich da
den deckel zu und dann werden diese etwa
20 minuten gedauert bis sie dann durch
sind
seit einem halben teelöffel seit 2001
norwegischen halbe und während das tier
kommt kann ich schon mal die zwiebeln
schneiden und die knoblauchzehe einfach
alles fein würfeln
und als nächstes nämlich ist das fleisch
und ich habe es zuerst die zwiebeln
geschnitten damit ich jetzt nach dem
fleisch dann direkt das brett entsorgen
kann also in die spülmaschine stecken
kann
und da spreche jetzt einfach hier diese
weißen teilnehmer ganz gern weg sie habe
für verschiedene dinge also die fleisch
und gemüse so verschiedene bretter
benutzen kannst du machen aber ich
schmeiße sowieso in die spülmaschine und
ist ja auch kein holz ja kein holz das
heißt es wichtig dass du dass du zuerst
züge stehen hast und dann die pute genau
und dann tue ich es gleich weg weil dann
hat man einfach keine keime später mit
in den anderen zutaten
jetzt habe ich die pfanne bereits
erhitzt und gibt da zwei esslöffeln
olivenöl hinein und jetzt berate ich das
fleisch von allen seiten scharf an
nur scharf anbraten unternehmen das
gleich wieder raus sondern kommt später
nochmal in die soße das rein passt
einfach nicht in den livestream erzielt
genau das ist sehr gut aufgefasst
wenn ihr das fleisch von beiden seiten
etwas 23 minuten angebraten habt nehmt
ihr es heraus dann gebe ich die nächste
portion mit rein
jetzt habe ich das fleisch rausgeholt
wird kann ich bereits die zwiebelwürfel
und die knoblauch würfel anbraten
auch mit zwei esslöffel olivenöl und das
fleisch das muss jetzt noch frei sind
und pfeffern
es gebe ich hier noch die das
tomatenmark mit rein und sprach kurz mit
an dann auch direkt noch eine prise
zucker dann kann ich die zwiebel mit dem
automatischen stücken ablösen
hab ich die hitze reduziert und jetzt
kommt das fleisch direkt wieder mit rein
und dann muss das ganze nämlich 20
minuten lang ganz leicht köcheln
dann wird sich das ganze noch dass ich
jetzt an dieser stelle auch direkt das
könnte hier noch salz und pfeffer
dazugeben und etwas thymian basilikum
gebe ich erst später mit dazu
und den fleischsaft dann gebe ich jetzt
auch noch mit dazu ich hab mich
eigentlich nur noch auf die kartoffeln
warten sobald die gas sind werde ich
nämlich das kartoffelpüree fertigstellen
und in der zeit ist es hier dann auch
fertig und da haben wir direkt schon
unter 40 minuten gericht
das kartoffelpüree brauche ich dann noch
150 milliliter milch 50 gramm butter
etwas pfeffer und muskatnuss
jetzt kann ich die kartoffeln abgießen
kommen wir zu beginn den topf und damit
erstmal zerstampft
gebe ich da direkt die butter mit rein
kommt nach dem milch mit dazu das ganze
auch direkt nutzen mit pfeffer und
muskatnuss salz hatte ich ja schon drin
aber natürlich nicht da auch nochmal
abgeschmeckt werden
und jetzt kann ich noch direkt die
basilikumblätter mit zum hähnchen geben
die jetzt einfach so ein bisschen geht
doch schnell
und dann kann ich eigentlich auch schon
die teller holen und das ganze anrichten
jetzt kann ich direkt anrichten und beim
kartoffelpüree muss ich sage peter
morath einfach ein bisschen zu sparsam
mit den kartoffeln
also da kann man ruhig ein paar
kartoffeln mehr nehmen so jetzt richtig
das schön an und dann kommt da pro
person jetzt noch so unfälle drauf und
etwas tomatensoße
sieht fast aus wie ein gesicht
jetzt noch ein basilikum blättchen drauf
und dann habe ich innerhalb von etwa 40
minuten ein richtig leckeres mittagessen
gezaubert vor allen dingen geht es da
schnell es ist sehr einfach man hat
wirklich wenige zutaten und es schmeckt
sehr gut
außerdem finde ich ist auch nicht so
eine kalorienbombe als auch ziemlich
gesund so sieht aus und das sagte murat
gleich probieren der sitzt gerade
unterwegs samira zum ballett fahren aber
es gleich wieder da und dann wird es
gleich mit unseren freunden zusammen
verspeist und mir das rezept nach machen
wollt dann geht auf sallys - blog.de
dastehst noch mal ganz genau
und falls ihr gerne rezept wünsche habt
bezüglich meiner kategorie was koche ich
heute dann schreibt sie mir in die
kommentare und ich koche es natürlich
gerne für euch nach
also viel spaß beim nachkochen und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal bis dann
tschüss und ich muss jetzt schnell den
tischdecken und sauberen und damit
gegessen